- Hey guys, it's me.
In this video, we're gonna talk about
how to fix a broken metabolism.
This is the most important
thing you need to know.
So, if you're doing anything right now
that's distracting you, put it away.
Get a piece of paper, take notes, okay?
The first thing I need to do
is give you a little foundation,
so you understand what
I'm gonna talk about next.
So I'm gonna kinda build on this.
So as we go, just take notes.
Number one, the facts about the metabolism
is that when you go on a diet,
you will slow your metabolism.
So dieting slows your metabolism.
If you've dieted for many, many years,
then your metabolism is very, very slow.
If you've never dieted,
then your metabolism is
probably a lot faster.
So, dieting also increases
hunger and cravings.
If you ever look at the
show the Biggest Loser,
they always make it look so dramatic,
like how can they lose all that weight.
But what happens, when
these guys start losing,
they start slowing down and slowing down,
where it's really, really tough,
until they have to exercise so hard
to get off that last bit
of weight, it's crazy.
And then they don't show,
they have to sign a waiver.
Many of these people gain
the weight right back.
And I'll tell you why in a second.
Also, age slows your metabolism, surprise.
You're probably already finding it out.
Exercise will increase hunger,
and cravings, too, with some people.
But mainly hunger, because
you're burning stuff up,
you're gonna want more.
And the last thing is,
it's very unnatural to lose weight.
Very unnatural.
Losing weight is anti-survival,
because fat is a survival mechanism,
so when you try to lose it,
it goes against a survival.
So really, we need to
dive in the understanding
of what that is so we can undo it.
But we're talking really
about your set point.
And set point is the point
at which your body likes
to be, weight-wise.
It just settles into a certain point.
It doesn't like to go below that,
it might not even go higher than that,
but it likes to settle
down at a certain point.
So my goal is to help you,
in this video, to show you
how to lower that set point.
So for example, let's say
your set point is 182,
and you want to get to 142,
so we need to drop the set point.
And that's really the metabolism point
where your body kind of settles into,
it likes to, the body
just likes to be the same.
It doesn't like to go down too much,
because that's starvation, right?
So what we want to do is give you
the next part of this foundation
of how we're gonna fix the set point.
But first we have to talk about
what destroys the set point.
Beyond just dieting.
So let me show you that.
Okay, so here's what you need to know.
Number one, you have this
thing called the pancreas.
It's located underneath your left rib cage
and the pancreas has about
a million islands of cells.
And there's these little tiny,
it looks like little islands,
in a bunch of tissue
and they call it islands of Langerhan
after the guy's name who discovered it.
But there's different cells,
and they're called
alpha, beta, delta cells.
The beta cells are the ones
that we're gonna talk about first.
And 60% of those cells are beta cells,
and the other 40% are other cells.
Now what is beta cells?
The beta cells make insulin.
So that's what they do.
So insulin is most known
for regulating sugar in carbohydrates.
So what insulin does is
lowers the sugar in the blood.
That's what you need to,
I'm gonna kind of build on this,
but you need to understand that.
So insulin lowers the sugar,
but the other thing is that insulin
also has other functions that a lot
of people don't realize.
Number one, it affects fat metabolism.
It affects protein metabolism.
So it converts sugar into cholesterol.
It converts sugar into triglycerides,
those are blood fats.
It basically increases the
tension on the arteries,
increasing blood pressure.
It retains sodium.
It drives protein, or amino
acids, into the cells.
And we'll get more into that in a bit,
but I want to just to have you understand
that insulin has a lot more to do
just than carbohydrate metabolism.
But for your viewpoint,
what you need to know right now
is that it's the thing that makes fat.
It's the primary regulator
that makes you fat,
and it actually blocks
any chance of burning fat.
In the presence of a
little bit of insulin,
you're not going to burn fat, period.
And this is out of guidance physiology,
and this is a known fact.
So it'll make you fat, and
blocks the release of fat.
Okay, so we have insulin,
that is triggered by a
high-carbohydrate meal.
You probably already know that.
You eat some bread, you increase sugar,
and what happens is your
body will store that
into a stored sugar called glycogen.
So glycogen is a series of
glucose molecules stuck together.
It needs potassium to be stored.
So we've got stored sugar.
And then anything excess
it turns into fat.
So we have a combination
of stored sugar and fat.
That's what insulin does.
And so what happens though
with a lot of people
is they start getting a fatty liver.
So it's really the insulin
that makes the fatty liver,
especially if the person
is not consuming alcohol.
And then insulin, if gone on too far,
will destroy proteins.
Yeah, muscle wasting,
think about what part
of your body is protein.
You've got intracellular proteins.
You have so many different proteins.
Your body is gonna waste those,
and it's gonna convert those into sugar.
And it's going to leave carbon skeletons.
So it's just basically
gonna leave the waste,
and it's gonna convert
everything else to sugar.
And basically, that's
what destroys a diabetic,
is that they get clogged
arteries, a stroke,
their kidneys fail, and then
they have protein destruction.
That's why they usually
have protein coming out
of the kidneys, and they destroy that.
And so you have everything
that kind of spills off
into the rest of the tissue.
So it's a very ugly, destructive disorder.
And then what happens normally
this is supposed to happen,
is before a meal, you
should have a blood sugar
between let's say 75 and 90.
Like, it's at 80 and 90.
But normal also it can go up to 100,
so let's say between 80 and 100.
That's normal before you eat.
What happens though when you eat,
the blood sugar should
normally spike up to like 120.
It could even go up to 140 after a meal.
But the closer you get to 140,
the more you're becoming a problem,
so if it's above 140, then
you become more diabetic,
because of diabetes, you
have this spike in sugar,
because the insulin's not
there to keep it in check.
So it's out of control.
So what happens normally is you eat,
it comes, spikes to 120,
and then it comes back down to normal
after two to three hours.
That's normal because the insulin
controls that blood sugar.
But in a diabetic situation,
it raises too high,
out of control, you get tired, brain fog,
and then it takes a long
time to come back and reset.
So now let's go on to the next part.
High insulin, over time,
or plus time equals insulin resistance.
Now, a good analogy would be,
let's say you live
underneath a train track,
and there's a train that
goes over your house.
And there's like a metro or something.
And at first you can't
sleep because it's so noisy,
but over time, you become desensitized,
you don't hear it anymore,
because you get used to it.
So same thing being
exposed to an antibiotic,
you become antibiotic resistant, okay?
So when you have too much of a hormone,
especially insulin, the
receptor that's supposed
to receive that hormone gets altered,
it compensates, it downgrades,
so it doesn't absorb it.
So basically your body's
trying to reject insulin
because it's too high.
So what causes insulin
resistance is too much insulin.
So you have a situation where you have
too much insulin, but you
also have not enough insulin
in certain places of your body,
like in the cells and in the blood.
But we have too much
insulin in other places.
So you can have symptoms of
both hyper and hypoglycemia.
Interesting.
So let's go through the symptoms.
Fatty liver.
If you have a fatty liver,
you have insulin resistance.
If you have insulin resistance,
you have a fatty liver,
because one thing will also cause another.
Because some of the fat in the liver
actually releases certain
inflammatory responses
that make you insulin resistant.
So it's really a nasty double-edged sword.
Brain fog,
high fasting insulin.
So even when you're not eating sugar,
the insulin is still high in
certain places of your body.
Remember insulin blocks fat burning?
Okay, belly fat, bloating,
digestive issues,
sleepy after meal,
so you eat lunch and
you have to take a nap,
that's classic insulin resistance.
High blood pressure, why,
because insulin causes
tension within the arteries.
Cravings and hunger.
Well, wait a second,
that's a low insulin situation,
but it's an insulin resistant symptom,
but certain parts of your
body have low insulin
because the cell won't let it connect.
So you basically craving
and hungry all the time.
Dark pigment in different
folds of your body,
like your groin, your armpits, your neck.
You have a little darker pigmentation.
That can happen in advanced stages.
And hunger between meals, you
can't go a long period of time
without getting hungry or
having a blood sugar issue.
That's insulin resistance.
So insulin resistance is
the single biggest problem
that controls your set point.
It destroys your set point, okay?
Why, because insulin is the
hormone that tells your body
whether to burn fat or not.
It's gonna become more
clear as we go through
the next part, too.
So insulin increases fat,
prevents the burning of fat,
and controls and destroys your set point.
Other than that, it's perfectly fine.
Let me show you the next part.
Okay, so now the big question is,
what causes insulin resistance?
High insulin, but what
causes insulin to spike?
You already know it's sugar,
but there's some other things that will
increase insulin as well,
and that would be protein.
Some types of protein more than others.
And what I'm talking about
is I'm talking about,
see protein doesn't trigger glucose,
so you probably heard of
the glycemic index, right?
Well, that's the level of the foods
that trigger the sugars,
but have you ever heard
of the insulin index?
Completely different.
I'm gonna talk about that next section,
but the point is there are other factors
that will increase insulin
that don't increase glucose.
This explains why you
probably are eating healthy,
no sugars, and you're
still not losing weight.
Now before you freak out and say,
hey, now I have to give
up protein, hear me out.
Because there's some other solutions.
But the point is that,
especially if you're eating
a large amount of proteins,
but protein does trigger
insulin to some degree.
If we look at the different
types of proteins,
well let me just save
that to the next one.
But gastrointestinal
hormones, what does that mean?
It means that there are
hormones in your GI tract
that also increase insulin.
So really, every time you eat,
you increase insulin, okay?
So, there's a couple foods
that don't increase insulin.
I'll get into that in next section,
but the point I'm trying to make
is that there's other things
that are messing you up
other than just the sugar.
Estrogen increases insulin as well.
Yeah, that explains why
women when they get pregnant,
they go through the menstrual
cycle, they get fatter.
Especially if the estrogen's too high.
So we're gonna talk
about the insulin index
in the next section.
Alright, now check this out.
This is the insulin index.
Very different than the glycemic
index for the most part,
but look at butter.
It's 2%, it's very, very low.
It barely triggers insulin at all.
Just slightly, okay?
Olive oil, 3%, coconut oil, 3%,
so really all the fats,
there's no stimulation.
And this is why you can get
away with eating the fat.
More than going low fat,
because watch what happens,
as we go up the scale,
we have lowfat yogurt, 76%.
So when you go lowfat cheese,
we get rid of the buffer for the insulin
and the protein is higher,
and you get more insulin.
So all these lowfat things at the store
are creating insulin problems,
because they're not using the fat
as a buffer for insulin.
And that's why even the ice
cream recipe that I have
is that heavy cream.
Look at heavy cream is 4%, okay.
That's low, it doesn't stimulate insulin.
So it's not gonna destroy the set point,
it's not gonna create a problem.
Now you can eat too much of it,
but the point is that it's not gonna be,
the importance of getting rid
of it is very, very minimal.
So it's much more important to avoid
the higher insulin things.
But check this out.
Egg yolk, 15%.
That's pretty low.
But look at the whole egg,
no the egg whites is 55%.
How many people do you know
that just do egg whites thinking
they're doing themselves some good,
and they're not doing the egg yolk.
The egg yolk is much
better for weight loss.
If we combine the egg
yolk with the egg white,
we get the whole egg, it
brings it down to 21%.
So by adding fat with a meal,
you're actually helping the situation.
Now it is true when
you go through ketosis,
you can be burning your dietary
fat and not your own fat,
but don't be afraid to
consume whole things.
Don't go lean at all.
Don't be afraid to use some butter.
Don't be afraid to use
some of these products.
So look at this, we've got
pecans, very, very low.
Bacon, 9%, see, in your mind,
you're probably like, well,
I need some lean bacon.
No you don't, you want the fattier bacon.
Because the leaner the protein,
the more it spikes insulin.
Peanut butter, 11%, cheese, 15%,
turkey, 23%, berries, 47.
Look at beef, 51%.
So these people that do the Atkins diet.
Let's say they do it the
first time, and it works.
The second time, it doesn't
really work as well,
and the third time it doesn't work at all.
Why, because dieting slows the metabolism,
it destroys the set point,
and they're actually
increasing their insulin.
Not as bad as the sugar person,
but that's really what happens.
Look at apple, 75%, lowfat yogurt, 76%,
banana, 84%, whole wheat bread, 96.
Baked beans, 100%, potatoes, 121%.
I'm going to give you a download.
You can download this page
in the download section,
so you have a whole list of this.
And I will also share in the extra section
some food plans to show you
what food you should be eating
just to take it one step further.
Now, I'm just bringing your awareness up
that there are foods
that are messing you up,
but they're not necessarily sugars.
And I want to show you next
this one little point here,
which is very, very, very important.
And I know I kind of spent a lot of time
getting to this point,
but this the most important point
of this whole presentation.
So if high levels of insulin
over a period of time
cause insulin resistance,
then what happens is we have
breakfast, lunch, and dinner.
So here's the problem.
When we eat, even the hormones
in our digestive tract spike insulin.
Okay, so we know we're gonna get rid
of the sugar and all
that, and that's great.
But if you snack in between the meals,
if you're snacking, even
with healthy things,
you're spiking the insulin.
So we never have a chance to
correct insulin resistance.
So you must shoot for
three meals a day, or two,
not to lower calories, because we're gonna
increase some fat, but simply to correct
the insulin resistance.
Now how do you know if you
have insulin resistance?
Well, all those symptoms.
If you have belly fat, you're
gonna have a fatty liver.
If you have a fatty liver,
you're gonna have insulin resistance.
If you have insulin resistance,
you're gonna have a fatty liver.
If you have a fatty liver,
you're gonna have
visceral fat around here.
So it's all kind of connected.
So the point is that you want to shoot
for only doing three meals a day, okay?
That's number one.
But here's the thing,
some people when they get up
in the morning are not hungry.
So don't eat, even though that breakfast
is the most important,
your breakfast might
be delayed until lunch.
If you're not hungry in that morning,
don't consume any food.
Only eat when you're hungry.
This is a lie to state that
you need six meals a day.
It's just gonna screw things up.
So we don't eat until we're
hungry, and then we eat.
Now, if you want a little snack,
let's say a sugar free
chocolate, or whatever,
you can eat that right
at the end of the meal,
but not in the middle of the meals.
Not between meals.
If you are so hungry and
ravenously craving between meals,
then we have to increase
a little bit more food
during the meal itself, specifically fat,
low-glycemic fat, okay?
And what that means is you
have insulin resistance,
that's why have almost like
a blood sugar issue there.
And then the same thing at night,
don't consume past your dinner.
Now some of my clients they're basically
not hungry in the morning,
they eat a big lunch,
and they eat a dinner,
and they're done, two meals.
And that's incredible,
because you're doing
an intermittent fasting
for the next period of time,
so you're gonna heal
the insulin resistance
and you're gonna lower your set point.
Me, I have to eat a breakfast and a lunch,
and I barely will have a dinner.
I might have a small, little
cal shake and I'm done.
So it's like 2 1/2 meals a day.
So you can do that as well.
But the key is don't snack at night.
You can drink tea and things like that.
And then the last section,
I'm gonna give you a
series of additional things
you can do to improve insulin resistance.
Okay, so intermittent fasting
is a very important thing
to implement, but you
don't necessarily have
to go the whole day without eating.
You can start with three meals,
and then go down to two.
If you want to alternate
and do every other day,
skip a meal, that's totally fine.
The key is as you do this,
you're gonna control your
sugar better between meals,
and you won't have to eat as much
because think about it,
when you're fasting, you're
living off your own fat.
If you have reserve to burn,
then might as well burn that up.
When you hit your goal,
you don't necessarily
have to do fast anymore.
It's not starving your body,
it's basically getting your body
just more efficiently to
switch over to fat burning.
And not burn your sugar,
'cause if you actually can't make it
to the next meal,
that means that you're just burning sugar.
So we have to improve this.
So there's several things
we can do to lower insulin.
Number one, apple cider vinegar
helps blood sugars tremendously,
so you can consume that with a meal.
If you don't like it, you
can consume it as a pill.
But if you're gonna do it in water,
a teaspoon per glass, okay?
Fermented foods are
much better for insulin
than anything else.
So fermented cabbage, sauerkraut,
that's all really good,
'cause it has vinegar in it as well.
High potassium food.
That would be all the vegetables.
Now here's the problem.
When we do this, when we lower insulin,
you're gonna be living off your fat.
And you're gonna have a
lot more fat being burned
which means that your liver has to process
a lot more fat burning.
If you do this without
eating enough vegetables,
you're gonna end up with a fattier liver.
So there is no choice,
you have to consume
larger amounts of greens.
You can blend them, you can drink them,
but you need to consume that
to keep the fat flushed from the liver.
That's the only way you're gonna
get rid of the fatty liver.
Okay, so then we got high potassium foods,
that's vegetables,
vitamin B1 is also, will
decrease the needs for insulin.
That would be a nutritional yeast.
Make sure you don't buy the
synthetic version though.
Fiber, it's also in my
adrenal day formula, too.
We have B1, it's a natural one.
Fiber, like if you're gonna do a choice
between a kale shake with the fiber,
like a blended versus a juice,
it's better to do with the fiber,
because the fiber buffers the insulin.
So we want fiber rich
foods, celery is great.
Fat, consume more pure fats.
Why, it's not that we're telling you
that fat's gonna necessarily cause you
to lose a lot of weight,
but it's very sustaining
between the meals,
and it has no effect on insulin.
It's gonna help correct it.
So what we're trying to do,
is we're trying to get
you to eat enough fat
so you can go longer
without having to eat.
The reason why we're going longer
is so we can reverse the flow
and not have sustained persistent insulin,
but have a low-insulin situation.
'Cause if you have diabetes,
and you constantly have high sugar,
well if you don't eat,
you're not gonna have high sugar.
So guess what, this is
really good for a diabetic.
And this is how you reverse diabetes.
'Cause what is insulin resistance?
It's type two diabetes.
But you can have a version of it,
doesn't come like this.
You can have a small version of it,
it's like a prediabetes situation.
Okay, so lowering cortisol,
that's with the stress.
Reducing the stress, doing
my adrenal techniques.
All that, removing body
stress is important,
because cortisol releases glucose
which increases insulin.
And reducing estrogen if
you have too much of it.
So if your period is heavy,
we can do the technique on the ovaries.
If you're taking estrogen,
not a great idea,
'cause it's gonna cause
you to gain weight.
Sleeping more is gonna lower insulin.
Exercising is gonna lower insulin.
We talked about vegetables.
So I gave you a lot of
things that you can do.
Go ahead and start with
the intermittent fasting
of at least three meals and no snacks,
and then try to go two over time, okay?
And watch what happens,
your set point is gonna go down.
This is how you fix a broken metabolism.